so far gujarati is just playing a  wonderful game  yeah i guess no choice for duboff  is knight b3 or threat now  yeah i guess it is  it is so that's why rugby one is both  barring the threat and activating the  rook  bish buffet just in case protecting the  pawn on e7 rook c7  d5  so that's why he went for this one here  here here click here and we have  some real threats  we did also one  with it one  yeah uh we left it  we left it  here after knight c2 yeah he did not say  he went for this and you're  exactly what we showed yeah this is a  slightly different order of the moves i  mean i started with rook c8 but after d6  rugby one you just promote the ball  that's  very nice very nice game by the way by  that um